ننوه الى هذا العاجل وفق تصريحات كتائب
القسام فان مقاتلي القسام دمروا خمسه او
خمسه دبابات صهيونيه وقتلوا واصابوا جميع
افرادها في جباليا شمالي قطاع غزه لمتابعه
هذه التطورات الميدانيه العسكريه ينضم
الينا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي اهلا بك معنا اذا لا سيطره ناريه
على ما يبدو على الارض
للجيش الاسرائيليه في شمالي القطاع كيف
تفسر هذا التناقض في الوقت الذي كان يتحدث
فيه المسؤولون الاسرائيليون عن سيطره نريه
على تلك
المنطقه نعم تحيه لكم لمشاهدي قناه
الجزيره نعم لا شك بانه هذه القضيه قلنا
سابقا بانه التوغل لا يعني السيطره على
هذه المناطق كما قلنا بانه لا يوجد يد
هناك موضع دفاعي ثابت لهذه الفصائل
المدافعه في هذه المناطق لكي يتمكن الجيش
الصهيوني من الدخول اليها وانهاء المقاومه
التي تتواجد في هذه المناطق وانما قلنا
بان القدرات العسكريه تتنقل حسب طبيعه
الموقف وحسب طبيعه الارض بما يخدم تنفيذ
عمليات عسكريه متعدده وقتاليه على القوات
الاسرائيليه بما بما تتمكن فيه من موارد
متيسره وبامكان تنفيذ هذه العمليات الان
هذه ال التي تاتي في جباليه حقيقه هي دليل
قاطع على انه الجيش الصهيوني في مازق
حقيقي في مساله القتال في المناطق المبنيه
لانه لا تتوفر لديه معلومات استخباراتيه
كامله عن القدرات العسكريه لكتائب القسام
وفصائل المقاومه وبالتالي هو يقاتل اشباح
في هذه المنطقه التي تخرج من مناطق غير
متوقعه وتقوم بتنفيذ هذه العمليات الامر
الذي يؤدي الى تدمير الاليات والدبابات في
مناطق مختلفه يضاف الى ذلك بانه عدم قدره
المقاتل وعدم قدره هذه القطعات على على
القتال في المناطق المبنيه هو دليل اخر
على فشل الاحتلال في عمليه القتال في هذه
المناطق والدليل على هذا بان القطعات التي
كانت مهيئه للقتال تم سحبها من هذه
المناطق نتيجه الخسائر الكبيره التي
تكبدتها خلال المعارك السابقه علما بان
هناك اسباب كثيره لهذا الانسحاب قد لا
تكون هذه هذا الامر هو الرئيسي في هذه
القضيه ولكن هناك خسائر وهذه الخسائر
حقيقيه يعني اذا نحن نتكلم عن تكتيكات
متعدده تستخدمها المقاومه وهذه التكتيكات
هي غ خارج سيطره القوات الصهيونيه اللي
متقدمه سواء كانت في الشمال او في الجنوب
نتابع كذلك هذه التطورات الورده من شمالي
القطاع سرايا القدس كذلك تتحدث عن استهداف
دبابه مركاز صهيونيه بقذيفه تاندم بمحيط
دوار ابو شرخ في في محور التقدم شمالي
قطاع غزه
برايك هذه الانجازات التي تحققها فصائل
المقاومه في تحديدا جبهه الشمال ما
اهميتها بالنسبه
للمقاومه نعم هذه الضربات هي ضربات كبيره
جعلت من الجيش الصهيوني الان في الشمال
يترنح بشكل كبير جدا نتيجه ثقل الخسائر
التي بني بها خصوصا وان هذه المعارك اشتدت
في الفتره الاخيره بشكل كبير علما ان
التوقف الذي حصل في في في بعض في بعض
الساعات او في بعض الايام الماضيه لفترات
قصيره هي كانت لمساله اعاده التجع واعاده
التموضع و وترتيب الخطط وتعديلها من جديد
ولكن يبدو بان هذه العمليات تدل على خبره
ميدانيه واسعه اصبحت لهذه الفصائل التي
تدير هذه المعركه في هذه المناطق وبالتالي
هذه الخسائر ترتفع كلما حاول التقدم الى
مناطق معينه يضاف الى ذلك بان هناك الكثير
من الج يوب ومن البؤر التي لازالت تسيطر
فيها المقاومه بشكل يعني او باخر خصوصا في
المناطق التي تم التوغل اليها وتم
الانسحاب منها الامر الذي يعني بان الجيش
رغم غله في الشمال بشكل كبير جدا عن بقيه
المناطق الاخرى في الوسط والجنوب ولكن هذا
التوغل لم يمنع الفصائل من تنفيذ هذه
العمليات يضاف الى هذا بشكل عام بان هناك
صواريخ لازالت تنطلق من هذه المنطقه اذا
نحن نتكلم عن عن فعاليه قتاليه متعدده
تشمل قصف بالهوان وتشمل اطلاق صواريخ
وتشمل تدمير دبابات ومركبات وهذا يعني بان
هذه المنطقه اصبحت بؤره لاستنزاف القوات
المتقدمه في هذه المنطقه خصوصا وان منطقه
الشجاعيه منطقه جباليا جباليا البلد اصبحت
هذه المناطق يعني مكلفه باهضه الثمن على
الجيش الصهيوني نتيجه الخسائر الكبيره
التي تكبدها في هذه المناطق وعلما بان
التكتيكات في هذه المنطقه يساعد بشكل كبير
جدا القوات المدافعه على تنفيذ هذه
العمليات لان هذه المناطق ذات تعقيدات
جغرافيه مختلفه عن بقيه المناطق فهي تكتظ
وتزدحم بالسكان بشكل كبير جدا نعم وكذلك
بالابنيه التي تكون متلاصقه ولا تسمح
بتقدم القوات الاليه والمدرعه في الكثير
من مناطقها نتيجه الحارات الضيقه والشوارع
الضيقه يضاف الى ذلك بانه قد تكون ترتيب
الخنادق او الانفاق في هذه المنطقه تساعد
ايضا على هذه العمليات واللافت كذلك ان
المقاومه في غزه لا تخوض اشتباكات فقط في
منطقه وانما الان وفق هذه التصريحات
لكتائب القسام تتحدث عن خوض مجاهديها
معارك ضاريه من مسافه صفر مع قواه العدو
في منطقه جحر الديك شرقي المنطقه الوسطى
الى اي مدى فتوحات الانفاق وعوامل اخرى
تعطي الافضليه
للمقاومه
نعم هذه المنطقه التي تم الدخول اليها منذ
بدايه العمليه العسكريه ها هي تعود مره
ثانيه لتنفيذ هذه العمليات وقبل ايام
راينا كيف تسللت مجموعه من كتائب القسام
لتقوم بالهجوم على بعض الخيم التي يتواجد
فيها الجيش الصهيوني وتم
قتلهم وغنم الاسلحه التي كانت لديهم اذا
نحن نتكلم عن عمليات ليس في منطقه واحده
انا قلت بان هناك كثير من البؤر والجيوب
التي لازالت تنتشر في الكثير من من
المناطق وهذه البؤر لا شك بانها تستخدم
شبكه الانفاق المتواجده في تنفيذ هذه
العمليات او حتى في عمليه الرصد وفي عمليه
المراقبه هذا بشكل عام ولكن دعيني اقول في
مساله مهمه جدا يجب الاشاره اليها خاصه في
التعبئه الامريكيه في قتال المدن عندما
توضع الخطه العسكريه يكون هناك تساؤل يجب
على القيادات ان تجيب عنها الامر الاول هو
ما هي القطعات المتيس للقيام بهذه المهمه
والامر الاخر ما هو الوقت المتاح لتنفيذ
هذه المهمه نحن نجد بان العمليه التي
انطلقت في الشمال منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه منذ اكثر من 55 يوم على الهجوم
البري والى يومنا هذا والعمليات الان تشتد
بشكل كبير جدا والخسائر ترتفع بشكل يعني
غير مسبوق يعني عندما يتم الان تدمير خمس
دبابات ودبابه لسرايا القدس اذا نحن نتكلم
عن تدمير اليات كبيره للعدو اذا انا اقول
بانه عمليه التوغل نعم هذا الجيش توغل في
الكثير من المناطق واستطاع خلال هذه
الفتره ان ان ان يقوم بتدمير بعض الانفاق
وما الى ذلك ولكن هذا لم يؤثر على البنى
التحتيه للمقاومه التي لازالت تستعر في
هذه المنطقه بشكل كبير جدا والدليل على
هذا بانها توظف الارض وتوظف الاسلحه
المتيسر لديها بما لديها من امكانيات
قليله وتوقع اكبر ما يمكن من الخسائر في
الجيش المتقدم في هذه المنطقه شكرا جزيلا
لك العقيد كري حاتم كريم الفلاحي من
اسطنبول الخبير العسكري والاسترات